um i guess let's should we start with a
bit of the history first because you
know a lot of people would be unfamiliar
with the idea of inflation being up in
you know close to double digits but you
know there was a period when that was
almost the norm for a while you can
presume can you remember what that was
like and what that did
to the economy but also to households
well really from the 1970s through until
the early 1990s
inflation was something that people
always talked about indeed i think the
best definition of
getting away from inflation is when
people stop talking about it and sadly
today they are talking about it
and basically inflation turns a healthy
economy into a sick one
because it becomes a process of
constant catch-up
you know your wage goes up
then it's my turn later on to bargain a
wage
i start to think you're getting paid
more than i am then you think i'm
getting paid more than you
it makes it very difficult for people to
work out
how expensive things are
whose wage is higher than somebody
else's
and that makes it almost impossible for
an economy to function because you don't
know what the cheapest sources of
supply or inputs are
what the cheapest kind of labor is
and what kind of job to take
and certainly when inflation reached
over 25
in the 1970s
this was something that really
started to wreck the way the whole
economy worked and your i mean your
experience at the bank
you know i know you were governor
somewhat later than that but you can
presumably recall the institutional
battle with inflation and the aftermath
of that i mean this was not an easy
thing to get back into the box it was
very difficult in the 1980s
first of all people tried to target the
behavior of money and that proved
difficult in the early part then
trying to use an exchange rate as a
method of bringing inflation down in the
end we had to have a very deep recession
in the early 1990s
to suppress inflation
and after that when we left the exchange
rate mechanism in september 1992
we introduced an inflation target the
bank of england gained a degree of
independent voice
later it was made fully independent in
1997
and inflation came down and stayed
around two percent and we've been there
ever since until the you know last year
so there was a very successful period in
which inflation was brought down and
people stopped talking about inflation
but but right now people like you say
are talking about it again do you do do
you feel there are legitimate echoes of
of of that kind of 1970s experience
right now
i think there are and i think it's it's
a function of
ideas i i think there was a serious
mistake in the 1970s in which people
thought that well if we accept a bit
more inflation we can have higher
employment and output in the economy
that turned out to be false
and then of course that mistaken idea
was compounded by some bad luck in the
form of the oil price increases in 1970s
and there's a real parallel to that now
in which i think there are mistaken
ideas floating around in the central
banking world
compounded now by bad luck after the
russian invasion of ukraine and say
mistaken ideas so i think the mistaken
ideas
are twofold really at present the first
is that
people i think
decided that when the pandemic hit
because output in the economy contracted
the right thing to do was to print a lot
more money to stimulate spending to
bring demand back up
but that's not what the pandemic was
about the pandemic was about shutting
down parts of the economy quite
deliberately
in order to prevent the spread of the
disease
and that meant that if you simply print
lots of money at a time when you're
producing less
you've got a classic case of too much
money chasing too few goods and the
result of that is inflation and we
started to see that last year in 2021.
that was the first i think mistaken idea
and it's interesting that it was common
to all central banks they basically felt
we must demonstrate that we're here we
must do something
but governments were doing a great deal
through in our case the furlough scheme
which was very sensible
other governments had their own schemes
this was a very sensible thing to do but
it didn't need central banks to print
lots of extra money on top of all that
that's generated a rise in inflation
followed by the mistake of course
that now
i think of understandably worried about
the impact of the russian invasion of
ukraine on energy and food prices
which is not the responsibility of
central banks so that's pushed inflation
up further but it would have been above
target in any event
it will come down
next year and the year after the
question is will it come down to two
percent where it's supposed to be and
the argument of central banks
essentially is
well we're saying it will come down to
two percent so everyone will believe us
and so it will come down to two percent
well that's a very odd way of thinking
about it i call that the king commute
theory of inflation it you sit there and
you command the forces of the economy to
bring inflation down to two percent
irrespective of whether you're prepared
to raise interest rates enough to
achieve that and i think the test will
be once we see
towards the end of next year how far
inflation has come down
central banks may need to do quite a lot
more
in order to ensure that inflation comes
down from what looks like being double
digit level it will come down but will
it come all the way down to two percent
and simply asserting that because the
inflation target is two percent then it
will come down to two percent is not
really enough and
most central banks have fallen into that
trap i think of just
believing that because they say they'll
it'll come down to two percent we'll all
believe it
and we'll set prices and wage bargainers
will all believe that inflation will be
two percent
but why will they believe that when
inflation is now close to double-digit
level
that's the challenge i think and and
that's a risk
do you include the bank of england in
that i think all major central banks
have fallen prey to the same
misconception
that just by stating an inflation target
you build into your models and your
forecasts the assumption that inflation
in the long run will always come down to
two percent
i think that's a real stretch
but the you know the bank of england was
was one of the central banks which did
do more quantitative easing more kind of
creation of money in the wake of covets
so
presumably this criticism goes to them
as well as the fans it applies to the
bank of england it applies to the
federal reserve particularly uh and it
appears they just shouldn't have been
printing that extra money they shouldn't
have been printing the extra money what
governments were doing
was enough
to deal with the consequences of cobit
and that your point is that has
contributed to what we're now seeing in
terms of the cost of living yes it and
it's true you can see it with all
central banks that they're now worried
about inflation when they weren't before
and it's not all the result of the
russian invasion of ukraine this was
foreseeable you think yes it was
foreseeable because
it was a mistaken diagnosis of what
needed to be done with the pandemic
in march 2020 people argued well there's
some disruption in financial markets we
better intervene and print money to
prevent you know a collapse of certain
financial markets
but that went away within a matter of
weeks
and at that point you would have
expected central banks to withdraw the
support that they were giving rather
than withdrawing it they doubled down
and did a lot more and i think if you
just print a great deal of money
it was most extreme in the united states
where the federal reserve
printed money at a rate
that was faster than
at any point since the second world war
after covert
after covid started 2020 2021 you know
their their money supply held by
businesses and households
was growing at 25 percent a year now
you don't have to believe in the
mechanical link between that and
inflation
but you should be asking yourself the
question yeah what do we think is going
on here you know if we keep printing
money at this rate what will happen and
the answer is obvious you'll get
inflation
but people have stopped thinking about
it in those simple terms
and they've become obsessed i think with
complex models
which
can be helpful in some circumstances but
it's not a description of how the world
works
and i think just asking the simple
question what is going on here
is a very important one to ask because
the pandemic was not like the sort of
business cycles we'd seen in the past
where people lose confidence stop
investing and spending you then cut
interest rates to stimulate demand to
get back to where the economy can
produce
that wasn't the position at all in the
pandemic
the governments and households basically
decided we'll be going to stop
functioning for a while
and
once supply goes down
the worst thing you can do at that point
is to increase demand because there's a
real imbalance between the two and if
you stimulate the money demand at the
same time as output is contracting
the result is going to be inflation now
the good news here
is that they're not printing money at
that rate anymore that's stopped so we
can expect inflation to come back down
the real question i think is how deep
will the recession have to be and there
will have to be a resistance i think
it's well who knows we may get lucky we
may get lucky maybe there's a solution
to the russian invasion of ukraine the
future is unpredictable
but
if inflation doesn't come back down as
quickly as central banks hope
and in particular doesn't come back all
the way to two percent but only to say
four
then they'll have to tighten policy
further and the particular worry at
present of course is that
the labor market in britain is very very
tight
unemployment lowest level for you know
50 years
more vacancies than there are unemployed
people for the first time ever which is
all good news
it's good it's good news but what it
means is you can't expect the supply
side of the economy is being really
constrained
and
this is you know with that tighter labor
market
with wages rising you know anywhere
between five and seven percent a year
with inflation nine percent a year and
predicted to go higher
interest rates of just one percent
don't look as if it's going to be the
vehicle for bringing inflation
right back down from double digit levels
to two percent
but at the moment markets are kind of
you know expecting what is it maybe two
two and a half percent in the uk is is
your point that that to you doesn't look
like enough well we just don't know and
i think it's a mistake to predict where
interest rates will go that's one of the
mistakes central banks have made in the
last 10 years which is to try and tell
us where interest rates will go
they don't know
and nor do we
so we have to be prepared for higher
interest rates
it's just that if you want to give a
very strong and clear statement that we
are determined to bring inflation back
to the two percent target
you need to do a bit more interest rates
now to give a very clear signal that
that's what you're prepared to do
i don't think you need to say where
rates will go because i don't think you
can know but you've got to signal that
you're prepared to take whatever action
is necessary so what would you be doing
if you were in the room well i i don't
give advice to my successes and i'm not
going to do that but nonetheless i mean
it for a very
respected former central banker to be
making these points
it is quite it's quite a serious point
you're making about policy you know here
in the uk and elsewhere as well and
there's a similar debate in the united
states where the federal reserve has
come out a great deal of criticism
for saying well we'll raise rates
now they've changed their tune they were
going to raise rates by 25 basis points
you know each meeting
that could have left them still behind
the curve a year from now
now they may well make 250 basis points
increases in successive meetings
my guess is that that's the minimum
that's going to be needed to demonstrate
strongly that you are really determined
to bring inflation down irrespective of
what happens because the big lesson from
the 1970s was that the two central banks
that were the most determined to bring
inflation back down in the 70s and took
strong action to do so
the bundesbank in germany and the swiss
national bank
not only were they more successful in
bringing inflation down they actually
had the
lowest recessions
by tackling inflation early
they prevented the need to keep raising
rates in order to create a deeper
recession
to stop an ingrained wage price spiral
pushing inflation up
and that's what's most important we've
been through you know 30 years where
people have got used to low inflation
they've accepted it they stopped talking
about inflation
unless we get back to that as quickly as
possible the risk is that people do
start to worry about inflation all the
time
and then wages are being pushed up
you get more industrial unrest
and you really need a deep recession in
order to bring inflation back down let's
hope we don't need to do that really is
the 1970s that would be the 1970s now
we're not there yet but it will need a
very clear statement and signal
by central banks to make sure that we
don't end up there
one of the things that you're kind of
pointing towards is that you know a lot
of this stuff was there in the can
before
the russian invasion of ukraine
and actually it's true i mean energy
prices these price cap increases
happened before that even though a lot
of people are attributing it to that so
it's your point that part of the energy
rise in energy costs which is kind of
the big
force of momentum here that this was
partly caused by too much qe too much
momentum in the system so i think it's
very hard to work out how much was due
to
that mistake in monetary policy and how
much was the result of you know specific
factors but what we're seeing now is
inflation is spreading across the
economy it isn't just in one sector
and that's got to be the the issue that
the bank worries about
stopping it spreading to wage increases
and to the service industries and so on
we can see in the united states which is
probably a bit ahead of us in this
respect
that their problem now is that inflation
has spread
well into the service sector which is
the biggest part of the economy
you know at the beginning people were
talking about you know second-hand car
prices etc it's all one-off effects
whenever inflation rises you can always
say oh it's this this price increase or
that price increase
no one
sits around and all prices go up at the
same time you can always point to
particular price increases
the issue really is what's the
fundamental force driving higher
inflation
and i think we've been through a period
in which interest rates have been
unnaturally low the idea that one
percent interest rates even two percent
interest rates
should be the norm i think is is a very
odd idea
to hold
do you have a kind of vague idea of what
the norm is in you know i'm not asking
for a prediction but i'm asking for your
sense as to whether that has shifted
from
you know five percent or so when
back when you were governor to something
else now
i think it's very hard to judge and i
think we'd like to get back to it but
not two percent two percent it's time i
actually think it's too low and i think
the
it's weak economic growth that has led
people to
believe that the normal level of
interest rates would be a lot lower and
i think that once we can
get to a point where
we restructure a lot of the debts of
businesses that have been able to keep
going because they could service their
debts at
almost negligible interest rates
then we can shift resources from those
companies to more productive companies
more productive sectors in the economy
productivity growth will pick up
and the natural consequence of that is
that interest rates the normal level of
interest rates will itself go back to
the sort of level we saw before okay so
yeah it's not it's not kind of you know
two percent is the norm forever i mean
i mean one of the interesting things is
that whether it's interest rates or
whether it's
the level of unemployment
people have an idea of what the normal
level is because that's what we've
experienced and then it turns out
actually we go through a period when it
looks very different
and everyone says oh now he's got a new
normal level but it's always changing
it's always changing it's just it's very
hard to see
how a market economy can function
with close to zero interest rates where
you're supposed to use the interest rate
to decide which investment project to
invest in
where the interest rate needs to be
positive to give an incentive to save to
finance that investment
to generate economic growth
interest rates need to be positive and
positive
having adjusted for inflation
well at presently they're obviously
pretty much negative adjusted for
inflation when when you you've talked
about a kind of error of policy
but has there also been an error i mean
i assume the answer is has there also
been an error
of forecasting because you know the bank
was forecasting basically flat inflation
about a year and a bit ago
and so what what's gone wrong there
well a mistake is to believe that you
can make accurate forecasts i mean
economists on the 1st of january each
year tend to make forecasts they're
always wrong
but there are good reasons why
stuff happens
first of january 2020
all the economic forecasts published
then you could have torn up a few weeks
later with the pandemic
2021
at the beginning of the year people were
trying to forecast how quickly the
economy would come back we had a second
wave forecast again didn't make much
sense
first of january 2022 no one forecast
the russian invasion of ukraine they
didn't build it into their economic
forecast so these forecasts are always
going to be wrong the more important
thing to do is not to pretend
that we know that inflation is going to
be 3.2 percent in a particular year but
we are trying to identify the risks what
are the risks on the upside and the
downside
what can we actions can we take
to mitigate those risks that's what
policy is really all about and if you
think about the risks today
the risks are firmly i think on the side
of inflation becoming more ingrained
into the system because we keep talking
about it we expect it to happen
and we adjust our wage demands and our
price
setting decisions accordingly and it's
very important to try and get back to a
world in which we
thankfully stop talking about inflation
once more
um is it is it significant or relevant
that that
that this has begun with energy i mean
does energy play a particular role a lot
of economists kind of
almost
try not to think about it just treat it
as an input but is there a significance
to the fact that there's you know we've
got very high energy costs and
does that make it kind of somewhat
different somewhat faster to previous
recessions well i think there are two
ways in which it is different
the first one is that it clearly impacts
different people in different ways
and it hurts particularly
people on low incomes
because you cannot change
your heating system you can't just say
oh gas has gone up in price maybe i'll
switch to it you know heat pump or
something you can't do that at all
quickly so you're stuck with it
no real action and these terrible
stories of people just switching off the
heating
illustrate the only course of action
they can take
so it affects the welfare of people on
low incomes
significantly
um
i think the second is
is a wider reflection of the same
problem
but the real issue here is that
we don't produce
all the energy ourselves
so we have to import quite a lot
and that means that when energy prices
go up it's a bit like the rest of the
world imposing a tax on us
as a country so we're as a country we're
worse off and there's nothing we can do
about that
that makes it much much harder
to provide help and support for those
who are hardest hit
because it's going to double down on the
hit on people
on average incomes or on better off
incomes and they just aren't enough very
rich people to tap
to trump make the transfer to keep the
rest of us
from suffering too much everyone
basically takes a hit when energy prices
go up and we can talk about how to
make it you know to help people on low
incomes but the idea that there is any
way which as a country we can avoid this
problem
isn't true when it comes to energy it
sounds like a particularly
toxic cocktail really well which is why
i said before that
when you get an intellectual mistake
in policy
and you allow inflation to start to rise
if you're then hit by bad luck
which is what happened in the 1970s and
has happened now
it becomes something of a
very unpleasant outcome
and it takes tough action and it's not a
pleasant period through which we're
going to have to go the failure of
economics is it or failure of
conventional yeah i think it i mean i
would not blame individuals in central
banks i think it's a failure of
the economics profession
to to believe that not the first one it
must be said in recent decades well
certainly in the 70s we had a similar
problem
now we've got the issue in which
people believe that they can produce
fancy computer models and you ask them
what determines inflation in your model
and they say the inflation target
and then you say but surely you can't
just announce
what inflation will be it reflects
what's going on in the economy and the
models don't take that into account
amazingly
so i i do think that there were this was
a mistake of the economics profession
which has spread
understandably into central banks which
employ the graduates produced by
by universities and they adopt the
conventional wisdom of the time
and i think it's misled us on this
occasion followed as i said by some bad
luck
is it um do you think this is a greater
challenge than than any that you faced
when you were governor but in some ways
i think it probably is though
i think the similarities that you went
through you know you had the financial
crisis yeah the financial crisis but i
think
in a way the the worse the situation
became the easier it was to know what
the answer was i mean i think in the
financial crisis
it was very
it didn't take very long to work out
that the banks were under capitalized
that the banks themselves had borrowed
too much and they were very fragile and
the only way to restore confidence in
the banking system was to recapitalize
the banks it took time to
persuade everyone to do it but
eventually we got there
now i think
again we know what the problem is
monetary policy has been too loose it
needs to be tightened
and the problem for central banks is
that
for very understandable reasons they
don't want to say you know
maybe we got it wrong in the last year
or so um
the you know the the obvious piece of
advice you give to a central bank today
is
i wouldn't start from here
but they are and yeah that's the problem
and
i mean there have been lots of there's
been lots of scrutiny shall we say of of
the bank of england
in the last few weeks
i mean that's there's going to be more
isn't there well there's bad to be more
when when inflation rises so far above
target
but i think the important thing for them
is to give very strong clear signals
that they will take action
to bring inflation down and they're
going to have to be patient
um just as we were in the financial
crisis the the first
six to 12 months of that were very
difficult for the bank we felt we were
doing the right thing and i think in
time we were proved right
you know i think provided central banks
take appropriate action now
they will see a fall in inflation next
year
and
no predictions but i think this will you
know the
very appropriate action meaning raising
interest rates quite considerably well i
i don't want to speculate on you know
how far they should do it but i think
making doing something which illustrates
that it's not just talking about it it's
its actions are they all raising rates
they're raising rates the trouble is
that present rates are so low relative
to where
they ought to be in order to have a
chance of bringing inflation back down
and
what i hope is that they just don't
leave it too long because then they may
end up raising rates
but at the wrong time you know
this is the time to do it
not in six months 12 months time when we
may be facing a much you know
more difficult economic situation um
put all of this together and
i mean how concerned are you about
bank of england independence this is a
story that you are you know you're a big
part of it you're one of the the you
know part of the origin story in a way
well i
i don't think there is a threat to
legal independence of the bank of
england i think any government that
tried to undo independence
would immediately see a very adverse
reaction in markets government the rate
at which governments could borrow but it
would go up
so i i don't think that's a threat i i
think
what is most important now is that the
bank has a very clear and simple
narrative i think
don't keep it too complicated keep it
simple
which makes it easier then for
governments to support and back
the central bank
do you worry though that you're by you
know intervening like this or making
these points as you are with your
reputation that that might then
give those who want to knock the bank
more ammunition to take them down well
let me be very clear i'm criticizing the
ideas of the economics profession
which have come to influence central
banks it's the ideas that are wrong and
i don't criticize individuals in it
because i think you can't blame them
first you know going along with what is
a conventional wisdom
what we need is a debate about the ideas
behind all this
and i think that's what's what's
important and if we can change that
narrative somewhat i think it would be
easier for the bank because as i said if
you look ahead they're not printing
money at a rapid rate now
so they have a good story to tell
about where inflation is going and why
it will come back to the target in due
course
but they've got to have that simple
narrative i think
in order to retain the credibility
which was built up
over a long period
since really in 1992 and a lot further
since independence in 1997.
25 years ago yeah 25 this is the
anniversary so it's funny how
i think various anniversaries there's
been a crisis that we've ended up
talking about more than the
successes of the uh of the past few
decades but if i look back at my time in
the bank of england
which i joined in 1991
i think there was a crisis every single
year in some part of the world which
affected what we were trying to achieve
uh but by the way are you passing are
you passing this advice on
you know to to colleagues at the bank
well i don't give advice
in public and whether or not i do it in
private
i will reflect on it i'm always there
they know how to get hold of me